what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we are gonna be talking about the belt
and road initiative this is something
that is kind of pushing China up as a
major geopolitical economic force in the
world and there's not too much
conversation that's going on about it
for some reason right now but it's
basically the most important economic
advance of the 21st century so what the
hell is the belt and road initiative and
why is is so important all right
well in order to really kind of
understand this I am going to pull up
this really awesome graphic that we have
and the the graphic is going to show you
kind of what China's doing with the land
in the eastern hemisphere and where
they're moving the goods and the
economics that are going on within that
area and so this includes China moving
Goods through Australia and through the
Indonesian area and through Southeast
Asia and through India and through Asia
and through the Middle East and through
Africa and through Europe so it's
basically the whole eastern hemisphere
is about to be economically saturated
with China's infrastructure roads
bridges boats the sea the maritime route
the the education systems the pretty
much everything is gonna be crazily
improved by China and we're gonna break
down exactly how that all works and what
it's all going to look like here and so
let's start by saying that you know as
you take a look at this dock that I made
I just want to show you guys that you
know all these things that I listed
about real estate the power grid iron
and steel materials for railways
highways infrastructure etc this is
going to cover 68 countries including 65
percent of the world's population and
forty percent of the total GDP which is
just absolutely
nuts 68 countries 65 percent of the
world's population of 40 percent of the
GDP we'll touch on this again so China's
government's calling this the initiative
a bid to enhance regional connectivity
and embrace a brighter future which is
yeah it's what they're calling it and
others like the u.s. see it as a push by
China to take a larger role in global
affairs with the China center trading
network and this initiative was unveiled
by Xi Jingping
and that was in 2013 and that's the
People's Republic of China president and
so as I listed you know infrastructure
investment highway you know we're
repeating a couple of these things here
because of the sheer importance of it
now I want to jump to this video you
know I'm gonna I'm gonna show you just
real quick that who on the map that you
see here on the video that we have but
it's also on Google Earth you know China
is right here and they're kind of
centrally located at the eastern
hemisphere all access to Indonesia and
and Australia and then they're gonna go
through India and the Asian area and to
get to Africa in the Middle East and
also Europe as well through this area
through Russia they've negotiated
partnerships with a lot of places so
we're gonna be talking about this
Pakistan corridor right here which is
very interesting yeah it was just oh I
was just showing oh in the mouse moving
but yeah you can see the mouse moving
it's hard to see it but just that that
that Pakistan corridor as well but all
right let's play the video and let's
elaborate a bit more on exactly what
we're talking about and we'll pause
throughout and we'll mention things
there's a new highway in Pakistan
in a new rail terminal in Kazakhstan and
shout out to Vox for making this busy
port in Sri Lanka recently opened as
well as this bridge in rural Laos what's
interesting is that they're all part of
one country's project that spans three
continents and touches over 60% of the
world's population if you connect the
dots it's not hard to see which country
that is this is China's belton Road
initiative our most ambitious
infrastructure project at a modern
history that's designed to reroute globe
right
pause obviously so if you ah we lost
where we were at it's all good
yeah yeah it's probably like 20 seconds
in or so it's with all the red dots keep
going yeah yeah right there a little bit
back right yeah right there so this kind
of gives you an idea of how the networks
are gonna be interconnected so I'll show
you here with this orange highlighter so
so China's gonna have a major access
route through Southeast Asian into
Indonesia and they're gonna be able to
launch through the maritime route down
to Africa this is called the Pakistan
economic corridor china-pakistan
economic corridor this is a big deal
because it basically cuts the UAE in
full first of all gives China access to
what is known as Western waters for
China China doesn't have any Western
water so this gives them access to
Western water that also gives them
access to there's oil here between Iran
and Pakistan that they're finding right
now
it cuts UAE the United Arab Emirates out
of the equation a little bit and they're
a little upset about that we can talk
about that more later and then they're
hopefully going to come up here through
the Suez Canal and then up into Europe
as well and so this is a very intense
thing that they're up to okay go ahead
and play again and it's how China plans
to become the world's next superpower
and you heard them say a China next
world superpower yeah that's right
its 23rd right and Chinese President Xi
Jinping is giving a speech in Kazakhstan
where he mentions the ancient Silk Road
a network of trade routes that spread
Goods ideas and culture across Europe
the Middle East in China as far back as
200 BC he then says an economic belt
along the so Patricia Jung a month later
she is in Indonesia then two sides
should work together to build up a new
maritime Sproat in the 21st century
these there are cool two phrases were
the first mentions of geez Legacy
Project the multi trillion dollar belt
let's give er up so what you what your
remember there's two of these we have we
have an economic belt that's happening
on land and then we have a maritime Silk
Road that's happening on water for to a
trillion dollars a very very low ball
estimate on what this is gonna cost
extremely low ball accident estimate
this is gonna cost way more money than
four to eight trillion dollars this is
the largest infrastructure project that
the world has ever ever went and
undergone so this is gonna cost way more
than that so just but the countries
interestingly enough are lining up to
take the bid from China because they
really want Chinese
15 billion 25 billion dollars to
stimulate their economies because areas
like like in in Pakistan Gwadar Gwadar
is the city in the southern part
Pakistan they're taking on tons of money
to build basically a new beautiful city
in a desert area right on the water and
so anyway it's stimulating their
economies in the long run and it's a
very worthwhile investment for them to
take on China but China is also owning a
lot of the ports along the way and
they're not sharing it equally and stuff
so this is very interesting to think
about as well go ahead and play
I there also the two components of the
plant there's an Overland economic belt
of six corridors that serve as new route
state goods in and out of China like
this railroad connects the China to
London and these gas pipelines from the
Caspian Sea Girt gas and I high-speed
train network in Southeast Asia loaded
with natural and there's the maritime
Silk Road a chain of seaports stretching
from the South China Sea to after oil
that also directs trade to and from
China the Bri also includes oil
refineries industrial parks power plants
mines and fiber optic networks all
designed to make it easier for the world
to trade with China so far over 60
countries have reportedly signed
agreements for these practice and the
list is growing because China promotes
it as a win-win for everyone
take for example the BR I's flagship
project Pakistan like many countries in
Central and South Asia Pakistan has a
stagnant economy and a corruption
problem it wasn't a popular place for
foreign investment they're talking about
actually an economic corridor seem she
doesn't want chana offered to build a
port in the small fishing town Gwadar by
2018 the port as well as a highway and
railway networks became a sixty two
billion dollar corridor within the Bri
it's where the economic belt meets the
maritime Silk Road and it's a foot north
country thank you so ah
we're learning that's good it's good
everyone stay with us this we're about
to be crushing it soon like we're
already we're doing okay now we're gonna
be crushing it once we figure this out
yeah that's pretty good Ron right right
there was pretty good go back a little
bit more a little bit more almost that
perfect all right so all right so now
you see here this is the china-pakistan
economic corridor CPC now I'm gonna take
that I'm gonna take I'm gonna dive you
into into what I have on my computer
right now okay so stay with me here we
switched it over to my computer now
we're on all right okay so this is kind
of this is this port city of Gwadar okay
and as you see here it's it's it's a big
deal it's a big deal for China to have
this access from China to this port city
now what else is interesting about this
is that I want to show you on my notes
here is that the reason why and the
reason why it says OB Oh are right
here's it's also known as one belt one
Road but it's more commonly now referred
to as the belt and Road initiative Bri
so china-pakistan economic corridor is a
significant artery CPEC so this is a
five to ten year investment period it's
significant for port construction
storage facilities energy projects urban
hub etc UAE wanted to be a major hub
they still are but apparently there's
also Olympics into Iran as well now I
want to explain why this is really
interesting this is a surplus recycling
mechanism which basically means that you
divert excess production from economic
centers towards larger markets in the
near periphery of these hubs so a really
good example is at the end of 1945 after
World War Two Germany and Japan were the
two hubs designated by American economic
architects to be this surplus recycling
mechanism so the United States would
throw all of the excess production to
Germany and
which would then Germany would further
pass that down to the rest of its
European constituents and Japan as well
so the three elements to SRM which again
surplus recycling mechanism is
industrial output labor and financial
capital so industrial I'll put a really
good example of this is how Chinese
steel mills currently produce excess
output that cannot be locally absorbed
by at a profitable level so at the
contrast the steel requirements of
Pakistan are high and its own steel
mills up face difficulties for decades
so again this is just a very common
thing here China will produce a lot of
Steel and then rather than Pakistan
having to go and make massive amounts of
steel they kinda can just be that
surplus for Pakistan and just pass that
down to Pakistan and the back stand can
build up a massive economic project
there and make that better so I don't
want to spend a tremendous amount of
time on this but I just want to explain
that Imran Khan's the current prime
minister of Pakistan and most people
don't know this but the Pakistani
population is huge it's 200 million
people which is massive
nearly the fifth largest in the world
with an underdeveloped economic
structure economy is only the 27th
largest and so you know we saw statistic
about the GDP being very low this is
from just last year in 2017 so now
what's really interesting is that it
gives China access to the Arabian Sea as
we as we saw here and then Pakistan was
known as another source of of lots of
economic prosperity in the past as well
so this is this is again so now let's
we'll you know we'll go back to the
video again just remember remember the
earth is a very small place and the
whole eastern hemisphere is being
gobbled right now by China in terms of
its ability to just and it's not to
benefit both countries it's like a
stance actually yeah go ahead and play
it
it's all good we're learning we're
growing
you were within the Bri it's where the
economic belt me too and it seemed to
benefit both countries Pakistan saw its
highest GDP growth in eight years and
forged a tight relationship with a major
world power China on the other hand
secured a new alternative route for
goods see she not plausible but in the
Middle East this parts really important
as well you got to remember that the
Middle East is a massive oil hub and now
China can receive oil from the Middle
East through the Arabian Sea and this is
a huge deal it's okay
learn and grow and learn and grown it's
fast forward us there quick wait I think
we're back a bit aren't we
or no maybe I'm wrong but yeah go back a
bit yeah go back a little yeah it's
right here
perfect so I just remember the fact that
oil is being moved like that across now
through to China through the Middle East
in the in the waterway and then also
from the Caspian as well so this is very
interesting go ahead and play especially
oil and gas from the Middle East through
projects like these it also found a way
to boost its economy Chinese
construction companies that had fewer
opportunities within their own country
saw a huge boost from Bri contracts the
drunkest tracks in the world are now
Chinese top 10 global tips the bouncers
very much more ease is a requirement
that it be involved in building these
projects Chinese workers migration about
to do Chinese workers have directly
built projects like this highway here
and a Chinese firm has worked with
locals on a railway here in Serbia
China's involvement is one of its very
few demands and that set these deals
apart so far see typically to get
investment from the West countries have
to meet strict ethical standards but
China's offer billions of dollars mostly
in loans with far fewer conditions so
it's no surprise that Bri has been a big
hit with the less democratic countries
in the region
China's signed agreements with
authoritarian government military
régimes this is this is quite
interesting as well as that you know
maybe this can become something that
digs us out of more autocratic
militaristic regimes because there are
definitely some players across the world
that do take their power to levels of
killing people that disagree with them
and things like that which is kind of
crazy and so we just got to basically
just make sure that I think it's
important that if China works with
people across the world that have had
histories of malevolence that it's
important to work together in that sense
to make sure that the relationships are
also benevolent and the United States
needs to do their fair share as well
because we've done our own share of
malevolent things as well and other
people in the world have been watching
us so all right let's play again and
some of the most corrupt countries in
the world it's even affiliated with
Afghanistan Ukraine Yemen and Iraq all
currently splintered by conflict because
if China's willingness to loan money to
unreliable countries many experts have
called the Bri a risky plan eventually
these countries will have to pay China
back but corruption and conflict make
that payback unlike they don't have a
recent court found in many of the
countries in depth of China are very
vulnerable including eight that are had
high risk of being unable to pay so why
does trying to keep lending because
there's more to the Bri than just
economics in Sri Lanka China loaned
about 1.5 billion dollars for a new
deepwater port it was a key stop in the
maritime Silk Road by 2017 it was clear
Sri Lanka couldn't pay back the loan so
instead they gave China control of the
port as part of a 99-year at least
ninety Jaya also controls the strategic
pillar in Pakistan's or it has a forty
year lease PACS is pushing for a similar
agreement on Myanmar and it just opened
an actual Chinese naval base in Djibouti
these are all signs of what's been
called the string of pearls theory it
predicts that China is trying to
establish a string of naval bases in the
Indian Ocean that will allow it to
station ships and guard shipping routes
that must either so
this is also a big deal this is kind of
China's had some interesting bouts here
in the South China Sea where they've
really wanted to take over a bunch of
the a bunch of the land there and make
it so that they owned the trade routes
there the whereas this is international
waters it's supposed to be shared in
many ways and it's not being and this is
a very it's it's it's it's very
complicated to understand but if one
country controls that area of water it
basically controls the goods of like
four billion people so four billion
people's a lot of people receiving goods
so just you know food for thought that's
over half the population which is why
they're very interested in doing this
but it's also potentially a major you
know economic benefit in a potentially
benign way so it doesn't necessarily
have to be you know malevolent control
but hopefully they're you know good
player in the sense but they have the
economic money to do so alright go ahead
and play around regent thank you
so while China's not getting its money
back it's still achieving some very
important strategic goals China's
growing influence challenges the status
of the US which has been the world's
lone superpower for the last several
decades but isolation is trending in the
u.s. meaning that they are investing
less and therefore losing influence
around the world alright give it your
eyes is China so I'm pretty sure we're
at the end of the video right pretty
close yeah yeah so what's really
important to notice in this final part
of the video is that you got to remember
that nationalism and political gridlock
are kind of holding the United States
back that political gridlock doesn't
exist in the People's Republic of China
it's a top-down we make a decision you
go with it and really at times that's
not that bad if we had a sort of agenda
here that was like we're gonna improve
we're gonna make a new transit
belt that makes it easier to ship goods
between North America and South America
and you don't get a choice with your
taxpayer dollars and we're making it
really really amazing technology we're
working with the private sector of of
all these different massive transit
companies that are really smart and
really good and it's gonna be
sustainable and alternative energy what
would you do really at that point would
you be mad no you want you would know
that the government is doing something
in the benefit and the private industry
and they're working together which is
what goes on in China and that they're
making a decision to create a belt down
to South America that makes trading much
easier between the two countries
speaking of which there also would need
to be a belt down here between Africa
and South America
and between Europe and America and we
have the partnership between the North
Atlantic trade as well as between the
trans-pacific trade on this end to China
and the Pacific nations now just
remember that this is a small planet
this is geopolitics
this is geopolitical leadership if we're
trapped in political gridlock we're
trapped in nationalism we are not going
to be able to sustainably progress
geopolitically over time we got to
figure it out what are we gonna huddle
in this in this cave and make artificial
general intelligence and hope that it
does something that can that all of a
sudden other countries in the world are
gonna want to buy our HDI on or genetic
engineering and all these new tools
brain computer interfaces and that we're
gonna make money on that and continue
spreading democracy through that we got
to figure out what's the best political
and economic strategy geopolitically
here and it's probably not to turtle up
for extended periods of time and
meanwhile the whole eastern hemisphere
is now has seeds planted like whose were
they gonna buy from here they're gonna
buy from Alibaba are they gonna buy from
Amazon when Africa needs cereal and
underwear and socks and the developed
world rises an undeveloped world rises
to be developed the world what's gonna
happen now does it really matter if it
ends up being who the underwears bought
from if it's Amazon or Ala but does it
really matter we don't know quite yet
but maybe it does matter maybe it is
more important
for the United States to have some sort
of a more of a of a geopolitical control
over things maybe it's good for China to
rise up and both work together in making
sure that the earth prospers okay so
that's you know that's pretty much it I
just wanted to make sure that you know
that we touched on the belt road
initiative what was going on in the
world kind of the it's a small Rock you
know you know take a look one more time
at at Earth here and you know you're
taking it taking one more look at what
we have here on earth and you know this
is a small rock like if I go if I go all
the way to the north okay there I'm
pointed all the way north you can sail
around the earth and we've talked about
this for a while you can sail around the
earth in this for tea right here this 42
to 50 degree latitude area you can sail
around it just like this in 40 days so
if you can sail around the earth in 40
days it's a pretty small place and it's
important to figure out who's gonna
geopolitically lead it and what that's
gonna look like and like let's figure
out because this is covering 68
countries 65 percent of the world's
population 40% of the GDP right here and
that's those are big big numbers that's
a lot of people that's a lot of GDP it's
a lot of countries and they're doing
some very interesting things and I'd
love to you know one of my goals is to
figure out how to work with China how to
make a United States China partnership
that Foster's are really beautiful
future civilization where US and China
can work together and make sure that we
cover things like existential risk and
make sure there's no AI race or arms
race or or assault robots weapon weapon
robots or weapons in biology so if we
can figure out how to work together with
China and support them in the veldt and
Road initiative and maybe the United
States can start a built-in Road
initiative to South America and to
Africa and Europe and Asia as well we
can make a better globalized world
moving forward that just works together
and that doesn't
get greedy or corrupt so let's work on
it you know meditations of course a big
part of that as well let's learn how to
tune in word thanks for tuning in about
the belt and road initiative we greatly
appreciate it if you guys had a good
time continue supporting us by watching
commenting below teach to people about
this don't just consume go create with
this content go and make cool videos go
and make amazing writings about this
we'd love to see that more and and send
it to us as well also join us on patreon
so we can sustain this grow this impact
more people with this please we got some
dope live events coming up in August
David Eagleman on August 3rd very
excited for that and later on in the
month as well we're very pumped to have
you thank you for joining us thanks to
Ron a producer-director much love
everyone peace